back from the dead tiny Elvis these are
the TV and movie performances of the
king nobody could forget
one of the most surreal intersections of
politics and pop culture happened on
December 21st 1970. Elvis Presley
visited president Richard Nixon at the
White House and the hopes of becoming
deputized as a federal narcotics agent
Presley though no stranger to Illegal
substances was reportedly disturbed by
the youth drug culture of the day and
wished to lend to support and influence
to the War on Drugs a photo was taken of
the two men and Presley was presented
with his very own badge there's no world
would this encounter is anything but
hilarious or at least that's what rock
and roll High School director Alan
arkush must have thought when he helmed
the 1997 Showtime mockumentary Elvis
meets Nixon hosted by Dick Cavett as
himself what's most surprising about the
film is how straight it plays the facts
of the meeting long time television
actor Rick Peters doesn't much look like
Elvis but embodies a king Swagger and
Charisma better than most even from
underneath he has another terrible wig
well thank you very much
apparently the story of Presley and
Nixon's White House meeting was so nice
they told it twice nearly 20 years later
another version of the story was
produced by Amazon studios in 2016. as
Elvis and Nixon featuring Kevin Spacey
as Nixon and Michael Shannon as Presley
director Lisa Johnson keeps the pace up
with a jazzy score and Heist movie
energy as Presley guilelessly gets on a
plane and arranges are meeting with the
White House whereas in our kush's film
the meeting is little more than a person
at the end of the story here the meeting
takes up the final half hour of the film
Spacey's full body transformation into
Nixon clashes with Shannon's
minimalistic to the point of
non-existent impersonation of Elvis I
don't even know if I know who he is
anymore the film's placement on this
list is tricky and not just because of
the distaste audiences today might feel
towards Spacey Michael Shannon is
arguably the finest actor here but he is
so miscast as Elvis that it feels like
an intentional Choice his gaunt face the
midwestern raspberry bear no resemblance
to Presley but at the same time there is
something admirable in Shannon's
commitment to the character as a man
first and an icon second
the 2005 Johnny Cash biopic Walked the
Line doesn't feature Elvis as a
character very much though he and cash
both got their stars as Sun Records in
Memphis and toured the southern circuit
together their stories diverge at a
certain point until then though Elvis
serves as a potent symbol in the James
Mangold directed film cash first sees
Elvis on the Street in Memphis and
follows him to the Sun Records studio
until owner Sam Phillips slams a door
shutting Cash's face laser as Cash's
career begins to take off and they're
booked together on the same tour he
tries amphetamines for the first time on
Elvis's recommendation and as Johnny
cheats on his wife backstage with a
local woman the sound of Presley singing
that's all right Mama creeps up in the
sound mix specifically the line Sun that
galya falling worth she ain't no good
for you actor and singer-songwriter
Tyler Hilton plays Presley and performs
his own songs a rarity for Elvis's on
film vocally he doesn't sound very much
like Presley but he has a good voice and
his natural confidence and Charisma as a
musician and makes him a fine substitute
it makes sense why the crowds in the
film would treat him like he's Elvis and
why Phoenix's cash with respect and be
intimidated by him
rumors and believes that Elvis had found
his death became widespread either
seriously or in jest almost immediately
after his sudden death in 1977 at age
42. but despite this there are hardly
any films or television shows in the
Elvis live genre one of the fewest David
Winkler's 1998 road trip Indie dramedy
finding Graceland the film stars
Jonathan Shack as Byron a grieving young
widower who gives a ride to an older man
who claims to be Elvis played by Harvey
Keitel he's trying to make his way to
Graceland in time to attend a party in
honor of his death along the way as
often happens in films like this the two
strangers share adventures and life
lessons kaitel seems wildly miscast at
first looking or sounding nothing like
Presley but there's a twinkle in his eye
and a sense of fun in his performance
that feels like a piece of Presley's own
screen Persona whether or Nazi really is
Elvis he's good company why would you
want to spoil that by knowing one way or
another
the most notable Elvis lives film is a
2002 horror comedy Bubba hotep directed
by Don coscarelli an aged Elvis played
by Bruce Campbell and John F Kennedy do
battle with a resurrected Egyptian mummy
terrorizing the East Texas retirement
home or they live at least one of these
men may not be who he says he is but the
film mostly takes help us at his word
that he is the real deal like Rick
Peters and Elvis meets Nixon Campbell is
freed by the film's comedic tone to play
Presley as a swaggering cartoon which in
a way feels more realistic than some of
the more dramatic low-key performances
on this list just what are you getting
at Elvis
I think you know what I'm getting Mr
President
we're gonna kill us on my man the film
itself is undercooked part it out to hit
its already slim running time it is at
times refreshingly forthright about the
indignities of old age but just as often
playing old people falling down for
laughs
one of the most popular depictions of
Elvis in the last 20 years has not been
on film but on stage the mega popular
jukebox musical Million Dollar Quartet
tells the story of a day in 1956 when
Presley Johnny Cash Jerry Lee Lewis and
Carl Perkins all happen to be at Sun
Records at the same time in 2017 writers
Colin escorts and Floyd mud trucks
adapted and expanded the show into the
CMT mini-series Sun Records musician and
Elvis impersonator Drake Milligan plays
Presley as a high schooler swept up into
the burgeoning world of rock and roll
thus far the series is his only acting
credit other than a 2014 short film
where he also played Elvis he's been a
contestant on both American Idol and
America's Got Talent and above all he
has the moves the look and the sound of
Presley down to a science the series is
a handsome glass on those Rough and
Tumble years and asked little of
Milligan other than to be handsome and
glossy in return
in all the Decades of actors playing
Elvis on screen it apparently never
occurred to anyone to cast an actual
rock star in the role until Jack White's
one scene cameo in the vastly underrated
2007 parody Walk Hard the Dewey Cox
Story John C Reilly plays the eponymous
rock music Prodigy Dewey white appears
in a scene taking place in the 1950s
showing up just long enough to
aggressively Mumble a karate-based
threat to Dewey for the crime of talking
to him there's two things you need to
know all right I'm a king and number two
is look out man perhaps before white
there was never a rock star with the
improbable combination of having a
possible Elvis impersonation and being a
big enough fan for lovingly skewer the
king's persona he's Elvis he's very
small he spends his days marveling at
how much bigger everyone and everything
is than he that's the premise and single
joke of tiny Elvis a 1992 Saturday Night
Live sketch from Nicholas Cage's first
and only time as host cage has long been
an avowed Elvis fan and many of his
early roles from Rumble Fish to Raising
Arizona to Wilder tart are played at a
certain rockabilly pitch the sketch has
two scenes that follow the same pattern
Elvis sits around with Memphis mafia
members sunny and red West delighting in
how huge everything is Burton one of
them takes it too far and calls him cute
due to his size Elvis flies into a rage
let's get out of the car on one hand the
sketch is little more than a vehicle for
cages above average Elvis impersonation
and some impressive for live TV blue
screen work but impairing tiny e with
his Entourage members it lands a
satirical shot at the way Elvis was
coddled and enabled by those around him
Irish actor Jonathan Rhys Meyers dons
the sequins and sideburns in the CBS
2005 mini-series Elvis which covers the
king's early days in Memphis up through
his 1968 Comeback Special that concert
works here as a natural climax that
allows Presley to go out on top in a way
he didn't in real life and also spares
The Whisper thin Rhys Meyers seeing
Dignity of wearing a fat suit Rhys
Meyers makes for an intense Live Wire
Presley in his private moments though a
less than convincing singer on stage the
mini-series makes the odd choice to have
him lip sync to the studio recordings of
Elvis's songs even when he's meant to be
performing live the series and Rhys
Meyers are refreshingly unafraid to show
Presley as unsympathetic and even
something of a weirdo
the short-lived HBO rock and roll series
vinyl was perhaps above all a failure of
imagination set in 1971 New York City it
follows bad boy record executive Richie
fenestra as he hustles everyone in his
life on behalf of his beloved labor the
fictional American Century considering
that it was executive produced by Mick
Jagger and Martin Scorsese and saw the
more disappointing how often the series
falls back on tired cliches one episode
however breaks the mold in The King and
I Richie and his second in command hear
a rumor that Elvis is considering
leaving his longtime record label RCA
Victor they take a plane to Las Vegas
have a meeting with Presley in an effort
to get him to sign with American Century
in addition to bearing a striking
physical resemblance professional
impersonator Sean klush gives a
surprisingly tender one scene
performance he sheds light on the king
in an era that is too often played for
Laughs or drug-fuel drama trapped in a
gilded cage above the Vegas Strip and
able to break free
in 2019 it was announced that Austin
Butler a former Nickelodeon and Disney
Channel heartthrob recently seen getting
mold to death by Brad Pitt's dog in Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood was cast as
Elvis nearly three years later director
baz luhrmann's dizzying Gordy buyer pick
of the king Premiere to Rapture us
Applause at the 2022 Cannes Film
Festival Butler more than nearly every
other actor on this list put in the work
to become Elvis he does his own singing
dancing and guitar playing in the film
in return lerman's camera worships him
from head to toe especially in the parts
of the film detailing Presley's 1950s
Heyday when he was young beautiful and
dangerous the screenplay covers the
king's entire life and Beyond perhaps
biting off more than it can chew as good
as Butler is and as much effort as he is
clearly giving Presley's had a Mystic
final years don't fit him quite as well
as a pink suited mama's boy of his early
years and like many actors before him
playing Elvis seems to have left a mark
it's been months since filming completed
but you can still hear it in his voice
and it's hard to
in the beginning to feel anything but
small compared to the best deal the
first Elvis in 1979 just two years after
Presley's death ABC aired the
mini-series Elvis it covers Presley's
early days through his army stint his
movie career and up through his comeback
special and the triumphant early Vegas
days what sets the 1979 miniseries apart
from its decades later counterparts or
any of the other films on this list are
two things the patient painterly
filmmaking of John Carpenter and the
megawatt Charisma of Kurt Russell in the
title role what's most remarkable about
Russell's performance here is the way
that he manages to make a full character
out of Presley while also working in all
of the famous Elvis impersonation ticks
The Voice the pals the swivel even his
sideburns look good which would have
been enough alone to put him at the top
of the rankings man I've been away too
long perhaps he picked up some Mojo when
he had appeared as a child actor in
Presley's it happened at the World's
Fair fifteen years later Russell would
return to the role providing the voice
to Peter Dobson's body in Forrest Gump
and would wink at it in 2001's other
Vegas set Heist movie 3 miles to
Graceland
[Music]